welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition this is a dimension
as vast as space and as timeless as
infinity it is the middle ground between
not seeing the show and seeing it it's
the channel where we explain it so you
don't have to this is the twilight zone
the show has just dropped its seventh
episode um not all men has a lot to
unpack from it this is obviously the
most heavily steeped in social
commentary and not only this season's
lineup but also probably the show's
history throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the episode and its ending
as well as what I took from it I feel
like I have to add a disclaimer to this
one that I am a white man
so yeah you may want to take my opinion
on this episode with a pinch of salt but
I'm kind of interested in what other
people think about this as I can see a
rubbing a lot of people the wrong way
especially with how the show has been so
far anyway this is full spoilers ahead
so if you haven't seen it yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
but that out the way huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's dive into
my ending explain breakdown of not all
men the episode opens with Annie being
asked out by his supervisor who won't
take no for an answer
Annie is eager to please everyone at a
new job and he insists that she goes out
with him once initially she turns him
down she eventually agrees to go on a
date with him and if that wasn't pretty
heavy-handed wait till you get into the
rest of the episode what this episode
depicts is a world where men constantly
hit on women and harass them depending
on what life experience you have this is
either something you've seen before or
have heard through numerous news reports
on sexual harassment and so on after a
strange meteor shower in the area all of
the men in the town begin acting
aggressively towards women and this
carries over to Annie State who though
initially receptive to her co-workers
advances decides to turn him down he
starts almost forcing himself upon her
and after she rejects him and things
heat up with him vandalizing his own
apartment her life becomes awkward at
work and the bruises caused by the event
stay with her longer than would be
normale this is obviously a metaphor for
how advances like this can stay with
women for long periods of time and that
men's actions have everlasting effects
Annie becomes frightened of men around
her and he becomes transparent at the
actions of Dylan his supervisor have had
a deep effect on her well I don't really
have a problem with this stance on
sexual harassment and so on it's very
clear that the episode has an agenda
against all men with everyone in the
episode becoming demonized at one point
even characters like Martha and Mike who
on the surface seemed to have the
perfect marriage still full judgment
appeals viewpoint with Mike boasting
that he's woke and almost patting
himself on the back staying there's
still some good guys out there
he eventually too becomes violent and
this showcases that deep down all men
have the potential for this the son even
tries to flirt with Annie and too tries
to come off like a good guy to her it's
difficult for me to not roll my eyes as
to how heavy-handed some of the messages
in this episode are and I think the main
problem I have with this iteration of
the show is that it deals purely in
blanket statements everything seems to
be very black and white
and while symbolically that is the sign
of the show that doesn't mean that it
has to transfer into the episodes
there is just no balance for me and both
men and women are victims of sexual
harassment so our rather than tacking
the issue as a personality trait that
can be corrected it pitches the idea
that men are inherently like this which
is just plain wrong whilst Martha's son
does himself become a victim to
harassment
he also Nellie transformed into an
aggressor which again wraps the piece in
a one-sided viewpoint anyway at it in a
party
Annie feels pressured by her boss into
working with Darren small and she
confesses to her friend Martha about the
date Martha rebuts this with I've been
on millions of bad dates just like
everybody write to me the showcases that
peals view of society is that we do not
even punish forceful behaviors because
it is deemed acceptable and normal this
just isn't the case anymore with many
allegations leading to public shaming
perhaps if this episode had have been
released ten years ago it would have
felt more relevant but in today's
society it feels very behind the times
anyway after the dinner party we learn
that all of the men within the town are
acting out
darkest desires this of course puts the
females in the firing line and Annie and
Martha have to fight to survive in the
new social climate which can be viewed
as a metaphor for society as a whole now
I do have female friends that have been
harassed by men however I think it is
dangerous to completely wash all males
as violent murderers deep down and just
yeah I understand it's difficult to
discuss myself as a man as there will be
hundreds of counter arguments but I'm
sure most will agree that this isn't the
case
not all men are violent or all police
are racists not all Twilight Zone
episodes are good anyway Annie
eventually diagnosis that it is the
meteorite that is causing the problem
with the men and that there has to be
another explanation to this entire thing
however this turns out to be wrong and
it's revealed that the meteor hasn't
actually been doing anything a men are
just being men to me this is just
ridiculous
and if this was the case then why has it
taken society so long to devolve into a
place where murder is commonplace
eventually coal Martha's son shows that
men are able to control themselves and
he fights back but this still signifies
to me that men are the problem rather
than the society that governs them the
big twist reveal that men are just
acting of their own free will in order
to be violent and that the cure will
always be inside them it's very on the
nose like fair enough if you liked this
episode but it's about as subtle as a
slipknot concert in the end and he
stands up for herself when being berated
by a man and it signifies the me2
movement finally coming forward overall
in my opinion the episode is far too
heavy-handed to enjoy I get it men are
bad but this is just another example of
The Twilight Zone taking a cool idea and
handling it badly there are ways to do
this with subtlety and grace but
unfortunately this falls flat due to the
lack of subtext and a twist that I just
cannot agree with as I've said numerous
times I am a white man so I will always
have bias towards things like this and I
of course would love to see a balanced
viewpoint on my videos if you agree or
disagree with me I'd love to hear it and
I'm always open to people
me I'm wrong or am I just saying that
because I'm pretending to be a good guy
make your own mind up comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the entire
season so far which will be linked in a
playlist at the end this is a channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for take the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]